we are on day nine of the hunger strike
was too strong
a day feels like a week here we all
think it's going to be a social person
24 year old salah is on hunger strike
with other asylum seekers
at his hotel in reading here where i
spent my last three months
for others there it's been over eight
months they're protesting at what they
describe
as lengthy asylum claims and poor food
many people have lost weight some some
of them have
had kidney problems we are relating now
so i went more than 10 times to royal
berkshire
hospital with many people
all have very bad conditions
and have a medical problems and because
of the food because because of the food
these photos were taken by asylum
seekers in the south
who say the meals they're given at
hotels is often
an identifiable non-nutritious sludge
lots of vitamins thank you
you're very welcome in west london
a charity says it's trying to plug the
gap this woman didn't want to be
identified
she has a daughter it's been miserable
she hasn't eaten healthy
food for over five months no vegetables
no fresh milk no cheese no egg no fish
imagine a kid who's growing and needs
all this protein and calcium
she doesn't get any of this for the
first time in my whole life i've had
suicidal thoughts
there are so many suicidal people in the
same place
the charity helping her says the home
office is thought to give six pound a
day per person
to some companies providing food but
that is subcontracted sometimes more
than once the accusation is that corners
are being cut
we're talking about the most vulnerable
people in our society they've
escaped all kinds of horrific traumas i
wouldn't even want to tell you about
and then get here and and have some hope
that finally in getting to a safe
country
that the asylum that we're said to be
offering
is um genuine and that we are going to
take care of people
but actually what we've got is a hostile
environment
the home office refused to comment but
one of the companies involved did
saying clear springs ensures that where
required three meals a day
are provided the food service provided
by our suppliers
is reviewed on a regular basis to ensure
what is provided meets the required
standards
and that feedback from our asylum
seekers is taken into account as part of
that review
salah however says they're not being
listened to and vows to continue the
hunger strike
fighting he says for the forgotten adele
robinson sky news